[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
NFL pets you love we are back guys we
are back it is the divisions rounds of
the playoffs it's the division rounds of
the playoffs how we feeling fellas
fantastic man this this is this might be
the best week of the playoffs the
division around because you have like
the teams who should be here you still
have like a lot of games so I'm a big
divisional round guy
Ryan it's the weekend of the Dallas
Cowboys Greg I mean this says this is
we're starting I don't even hey this
whole time this whole time I didn't even
see you had that on bro I swear I did
not know right here I would have went to
go put my kid early if I would have knew
that we were starting this early that's
how we're starting it well welcome to
the show that's how we're going to start
this show welcome to the show it's the
division round uh like my man Sam said
some teams are not supposed to be here
I.E my man all the way to the far right
of your screen his team is not supposed
to be here but they're here and they
play uh my team tomorrow we're going to
get to that but yeah we have a match up
today we have some matchups today uh but
before we get into the matchups before
we need you guys to help us with our
parlay I have to introduce
the man next to me and the man next to
him well let's start off like this my
name is Greg Ivory and next to me is the
man I like to call the man the myth the
legend I call him s dot I call him a
whole bunch of things but you might know
him as Sam Richmond and next to him is
the man on this show we like to call
producer Ryan uh so we're giving out our
Best Bets later on the show
um drop your locks in the chat right now
because we will be grading your picks at
the end of the show
but we need your help to build this
divisional round anytime touchdown
parlay Ryan tell the people what we need
from it we need your locks so it's four
legs this week so I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna sit here one from each game one
from each game exactly so I'm not gonna
sit here and plea plea for juice because
we're gonna get plenty of juice if this
is four legs I like that yeah so come in
let us know your locks if you like
Boston Scott maybe we say yes this time
maybe we say every time we say no he
scores a touchdown uh but one from every
game uh hopefully this parlay lasted
till tomorrow and hopefully we ride off
into the sunset hopefully it doesn't die
this afternoon yeah that's true maybe we
should build maybe we should place the
four-legger and then also play the place
a two-legger with just tomorrow's games
in case we're close today yeah yeah give
ourselves multiple chances should though
should the two-legger tomorrow be the
same two legs that we use in this one
today yeah oh
that's a good question probably
yeah probably if we're if we're
confident you got to be confident right
yeah yeah all right so should we have
should we go should we start game by
game sure should we have the people to
start Jaguars Chiefs anytime and just
like boom boom boom boom boom yeah Sam
you're you're thinking we were thinking
alike uh let's just go in order let's
connect dots okay so we got uh uh
doctor87 Zay Jones and all caps and many
exclamation points uh DJ Mari Travis
Kelsey
can you unravel it on the screen Ryan so
we can see the odds because oh you know
the chat's not dropping odds yeah
uh where's Zay Jones is down here plus
200. now listen on it on a regular
slate regular season show I'd be all
over this plus 200 I'd love it but we
need to see one go through the hoop
especially on the first game on the
first one yeah
hey you guys know who I like kind like
Jared McKinnon I knew you're gonna say
that yeah he's like balling I'm I'm just
you know it's it's not my I'm a
controversial one kind of under the
radar
Travis Kelsey not someone you normally
think of for Anytime TD yeah right but
the Jags in all seriousness the Jags
really do struggle defending the tight
end and obviously Kelsey is
is a God so I you know if we did want to
start out with a nice you know a nice
leg to get this going I I don't think
it's the worst option in the world
I'll say this we've got d uh dgx
dropping McKinnon as well uh Swift 218
Canary's Tony let's just no no yeah but
11 A.D 11 has dropped several times and
he he adds an extra M at the end of yeah
he adds an extra M at the end of Ingram
every time that we don't read his
comment uh here's the thing I I'm with
you on Travis Kelsey I I would I'm
getting ready to ask thumbs up thumbs
down but for the people who are spamming
this chat with Zay Jones and Evan Ingram
can you please give us a good reason as
to why that is a better bet than Travis
Kelsey to score a touchdown because I
currently can't find one
yep
I I I do think your point is right of
like
it's gonna be a bummer if you got this
four-legger and it's done off the bat
it's like we want to like start the
weekend with like oh my God we actually
have a chance when people are pulling
this out in the chat as well uh oh
we got a scoopler yeah
in the NFL which is you saw that yeah
defending tight ends
um you know I I think Kelsey I think
Kelsey might be the move yeah start off
with a winner get the juice is Flowing
you know grab a couple beers crap a
couple white claws like you know sit
back and relax and enjoy Kelsey scoring
beer sad white cloth you mix it
I'm just you know some people are beer
people some people call people I'm
actually a car guy so you know
you don't give me feel like High Noon
guy actually a noon guys but yeah
um all right so we've got Harley
no go ahead should we do the thumbs up
thumbs down or should we just assume
it's Kelsey I think we're locked in but
we can do thumbs up thumbs down for
engage like how about this can we do
thumbs up thumbs down after the Giants
Eagles won because like this this
shouldn't be a debate this is right
right right right I'm actually glad to
Greg that we got Ryan on board with us I
thought he was I know so yeah Good Vibes
I don't wanna I don't want to delay
building this parlay but last night I'm
sitting around and I'm thinking in my
head I'm like if we took the chalkiest
play from every single one of these
games and built it into a four like
parlay what would the juice be and I was
satisfied with it so as long as you have
a good reason I prepared myself so as
long as you have a good reason I'll be
I'll be on your side
you gotta prepare yourself every night
before every show Ryan because I love
this energy
the chat by the way all thumbs up here
uh all right so let's get to let's get
to Giants and uh fraud Adelphi Eagles
here so
what do we like Jalen hurts is injured
that is a fact he is playing but he is
hurt he is off the injury report I
didn't take him off this week but
they're lying but yeah I I am with you
to an extent
um about like we still don't fully know
how healthy he is yeah hey
imma just say this I'm sorry guys I
don't mean to mess up the juju and this
isn't Greg's parlay but saquon Barkley
is scoring today
that's where my mind was going to say
well Barkley is scoring today I feel
like okay we got some saquan from uh
Mike Ritter in here I I have a I have a
suggestion and this one is one of the
juicier ones but I I have reasoning
behind it because I've been betting this
guy to score a touchdown for weeks now
and he's made me Rich Isaiah Hodgins is
down here at plus 265. and I know you
look at that and you go well you know
it's 265. let me pull up his let me pull
up his numbers he scored last week I
know he's a little banged up with the
ankle but hold on
let me get a game log here
last week he scored a touchdown against
Indianapolis he scored a touchdown
December 24th he scored a touchdown
didn't score a touchdown against
Washington on December 19th and then had
two straight weeks after that of scoring
a touchdown so since he's pretty much
joined the Giants on December 4th I know
he's been on there earlier than that but
since he started getting targets he's
only not scored in one game
I I don't hate it but I also don't think
that you're going to be able to get the
chat to go with Hodgins when you've got
saquan Devante Smith who's on fire AJ
Brown Jalen hurts on the board I will
say I will say Greg you as you know as
the men of the people uh look at the
chat DJ Mori says the rat is right okay
well didn't want to read that one okay
the rat is right hahaha uh D Brown says
Hodges trig away says I like Isaiah for
real bad a boy says yes Ryan Yes Hodgins
uh mktario says lock it in this is I'm
telling you I'm telling you that I know
that this is sounds crazy
right do your thing do your thing hey
let's go yeah this is
hey Ryan that's how you get the people
to back you up yeah see
wow look at this like he just locked it
in and moved on to the next game and
said like no thumbs up no thumbs down
the chat is knocking like that okay we
can all right uh bang on locks this Ryan
guy is truly cherry picking chat rat
Bagel locks needs to find God uh okay
let's do this we're on to Sunday but
let's thumbs up thumbs down this parlay
so far so let's I'll scroll up for
everyone it's Travis Kelsey Isaiah
Hodgins currently we're at two legs Plus
500. thumbs up thumbs down hey Ryan um
yeah but while we while we get those
thumbs up thumbs Downs are you seeing
the Boston Scott love in the comments
this is this is my issue this is my
issue with Boston Scott today everyone
in the world is on Boston Scott I like
Boston Scott when you're not thinking
about Boston Scott that's a good take
like once yeah Michael Ritter did a meme
about betting Boston Scott today I was
like this it was over it's over yeah the
second is right the second that Ritter
uh gives a take on anytime touchdown you
know it's cooked right it's cooked yeah
um it's it's kind of mixed honestly yeah
I was just looking at it I was trying to
get a read it's like it makes well we
don't count again we don't count Ritter
we don't count Ritter he doesn't know
any time touchdown it's more positive
than I expected to be honest yeah I
thought it was gonna be like 90 no
the the only thing is like most of the
people who are saying no are like do
Boston Scott instead of Isaiah Hodgins
and I feel like so we're not it's not
like we're getting like do AJ Brown do
miles Sanders do saquon it's that or
Ritter says it's caked
or um
or or should we like put like someone
else in there and just see how they
react like we threw us yeah yeah yeah or
Divine James Smith we get together we
can see yeah that's a good read Sam
that's a good one I think I think the
only other one that we seriously
discussed was saquon so yeah all right
let's throw my thing is why is people
second guessing Travis Kelsey they're
saying that he hasn't scored in a while
that means he's due right and again it's
the match-up it's yeah yeah I mean it's
a matchup all right he hasn't scored
he's still like the best player on the
field or you know weapon on the field
is Fletcher cut and Fletcher Cox is
playing is Jordan Davis playing today
I believe so let me look up
I don't know man
's saying bro we've been we've been
saying AJ rails I haven't seen it man
I haven't seen Ryan what are we talking
about do we not want to do uh take one
because of the defensive tackles playing
yeah
I mean those guys are nasty up front
like
they are natural you're you're not
that's tough man I I think the job I
think we're the way that we're seeing
this the way that you're seeing this
game Sam I I see it a little bit
differently but I think the Giants are
going to need to throw the ball a little
bit more than they'd probably like today
no I agree with that like I I hadn't
taken the Eagles to win this game I
think right you know but
take one's really good
um I don't know it's tough I I just like
I I think we had Hodgins and we were
cool with it if we want to revisit this
so we can revisit this but I think I
think we got enough it was like I'm down
I'm down to key positive if Greg is on
board with Cuban Hodgins and yeah the
people spoke all right the people it
wasn't like yeah it was like 50 50 which
is pretty good for a plus 265. I'll say
that yes all right let's that is good
let's get to Bengals and bills okay
let's do it
this game is going to be tricky to
figure out this is going to be a
shootout bro you think it's that option
is here yes we got Jamar Chase we got
Stefan Diggs we got Gabriel Davis God
see it you know this is like this is
actually the spot where I would be more
likely to go a little juicy because
tossing ox man I you know I Gotta Give
Ryan credit Ryan has been in on the
tight ends and every time I look up
Dawson and Don Schultz are scoring
touchdowns every time so you know we're
getting along a little too well today
yeah I'll say this The Vibes are a
little too high right now not to be a
Vibe killer I know bro that's a good
thing I know I know it's just this maybe
throw knocks in there and then you know
maybe we revisit Giants Eagles and throw
it you know yeah
um yeah I knew that there was a catch to
all of this
well I mean we could go if we go like
Knox and Schultz what is that gonna be
like 20 to one uh here's okay so here's
the thing 25 one here here's the thing I
don't know what just happened here
um
we made too good of a parlays that the
site broke yeah
um my thing uh Greg with Dalton not to
talk about this game but like I just I
Fred Warner scares the living hell out
of me I don't know if Dalton Schultz is
going to be able to score in that the
best the best coverage linebacker in the
game that's what I mean like and I love
Dalton Schultz and I know Dak loves
Dalton Schultz but like I'm a little
more off of Dalton Schultz on this game
than I usually am Ryan is it possible to
pull up the the anytime TDS for this
game
foreign
says no one wanted to keep Hodgins bro
yes we did yes you did what are we doing
the people spoke right I got your back
bro I got your back the people people
like Knox
somebody said James Cook
uh bro James Cook
T Higgins I think this is going to be a
shootout
uh bowling says one of these QBs is
scoring on God no cap I mean we could
have done with the without the on God no
cap part
yeah I don't I don't I totally disagree
with its take oh his take my take was
good too though right yeah yeah thank
you
um
uh that's a tough one yeah this is tough
because I also don't necessarily know if
like the big like I I think Josh Allen
probably score I don't know like if I
mean Joe if we're taking Joe burrow
we're taking that's some serious juice
and I don't think we need to yeah I
don't we don't need to play with fire
yeah no no no no no no
Josh Allen
I don't hate that
I I need more takes from the chat we're
getting James Cook I don't hate it but
it's like for I like knocks more
uh are you talking about James Cook are
you talking about Josh Allen Joshua Cole
Beasley anytime touchdown for the Vibes
what fives are those last week
[Laughter]
I was from our our friend Michael Ritter
uh leak just dropped a good point and
this may be the time to take a little
bit more juice uh we're forgetting that
we're getting one of the greatest gifts
uh God has ever bestowed on Sports
Bettors and that is Eli Apple covering
Stefan books yeah no that is a good take
and that's what leak dropped leak said
Bengals Corners are cooked Stefan takes
that is a good thing yeah yeah that is a
good take I I don't mind throwing digs
in there yeah we over thought it a
little bit okay yeah okay cool all right
so we're at 1087 right now so if you're
if you're just joining us it's Travis
Kelsey Isaiah Hodgins Stefan Diggs is
this the game we take a running back we
haven't taken a running back yet what in
the last game yeah in the last game yeah
take CMC call it a day
hey hey no but but but but but but Ryan
uh Cole Beasley is getting some
Donuts
also Dawson Knox is as well I don't know
I like knocks I don't hate Knox if how
about this before which would be
breaking the rules so we're not gonna do
it but I I would rather take like
digs and knocks and knockout options can
we stop doing this every time you have a
table it's just risky it's risky what is
risky about the statistics I read you
there's nothing risky about the
statistics I read you he scores every
game
is that really breaking the rules it is
breaking the rules unfortunately oh okay
yeah okay okay uh okay wait before we
move on to this last game and it's
either CMC or Pollard is basically what
we're getting in the chat we got I'm
getting some iuk and Debo but uh
I would say thumbs up before what how do
we want to decide just drop digs or
knocks
yeah yeah yeah let's just drop jigs or
knocks whichever one we see more will
just rock with it okay yeah how are we
counting are we counting are we cherry
picking or like are we like the first 10
people whose comment will like We'll add
that up so you gotta get in your comment
quick if you want your vote to be
counted does okay all right
Fair
uh
hey that boy Mike Ritter says CMC is a
green Gabby for Show rap this this thing
is baked
[Laughter]
they say drop digs digs I see a Knocks I
see a Higgins people aren't really
following the rules which is tax
uh
it does it seems a little more digs it
seems like yeah yeah she did yeah I
agree with you though Sam it's just like
if he cooks Eli Apple we're gonna feel
like idiots but I also agree with you
that I think Dawson knocks scores yeah
and this parlay is this is
all right so what are we doing for the
last one do you want to go CMC because
he came through for us last week
oh that's we we live on a we live on a
week's week basis so like one of the
most you know talented guys in the
league
nah I I like CMC a lot but you guys know
who's sneaky here it's two sneaky picks
we got Brandon ayuk and George Kittle
those are two sneaky picks that I think
that you know has been a touchdown
machine with Purdy like
besides last week it's he scored with
him every week
the only problem with Kittle is is he's
still only he's getting like three to
four targets a game now they're all like
in the red zone so you know but his
Target count isn't like is is kind of
low
um whereas I feel like
talk to us Ryan
because because I feel like strong CNC
and let's check to see yeah it's gonna
be it's going to be good I was just
gonna say I feel like everybody in the
chat everybody on this live stream we
all know who we want to take right like
we all know CMC is the pick but you know
I have any any banter to that any uh
pushback the only pushback I have is
that whoever I'm about to say to you is
obviously going to be better odds right
it's not going to get better than CMC
minus 155 it's not going to get worse
than that
I think Tony Pollard is going to score
and I think he may score more than once
I think this is going to be the Tony
Pollard game I really do Zeke does this
every year where he starts to break down
towards the end and he's really more
just your short yardage kind of like
bulldozed through and I think Pollard is
healthy he's explosive
I don't think the problem is the Cowboys
might get shut out so you gotta fast
without it
they might not get in the end zone at
all if you want you want my actual you
want my actual real but I know that this
is not going to be entertained Dak
Prescott has played in four playoff like
the last four playoff game stack
Prescott has played in he has both
thrown a touchdown pass and ran one in
yeah
but every day we're looking at like 35
to one like if we did if we did Dak what
would it be it's gonna be like 40 to 1.
70.
they say you're biased Ryan stop it
somebody also says CMC deserves no
pushback
yeah probably CMC you're right because
let's just say like let's say hodgin
scores tonight and we're looking at
tomorrow of having Diggs and McCaffrey
away from 18 to one we're feeling pretty
good we're feeling pretty damn good
heading tomorrow nah facts facts facts I
feel like all we need is Hodgins we get
Hodgins to get an Enzo that's the thing
you know in the last 30 seconds I've
kind of gone the other way of like
everything else is kind of like blocky
so it's like if we just get Hodgins in
that moment it could be very electric
like it will be I will unfortunately be
in the air 10 000 feet in the air so I
won't be able to see that but 30 000. I
was gonna say that's very low
[Laughter]
no I need Ryan here that's the thing I
need Ryan
uh I
think it's in uh we're gonna have fun
tomorrow
this is I I'm I'm in on this parlay I
think this is Good Vibes I'm I'm glad
I'm glad we had Hodgins I'm glad we're
netted out I'm in on it yeah James
Wiseman again wow James Wiseman you
haven't been banned by by the NBA yet
that's crazy but James wiseman's in here
saying 49ers offense literally revolves
around CMC
so I'm with it I think though the odds
reflect the likelihood of him scoring so
uh do we want to do thumbs up thumbs
down do we want to just you know Mary
Mendel dealer No Deal
I mean what are we what like if we do
thumbs up thumbs down they have to put
what they want changed you know what I'm
saying and I don't want to hear it
honestly
I like this far away I like this parlay
a lot I feel like we feel too good about
it
um and we already asked about the
Hodgins leg and there's enough possible
positive momentum that you know I think
it's in yeah Rel says not a bad parlay
like it trigger away says great parlay
Darien all right darian85 darian85 hold
on this guy has been on my side for
weeks I love Darian jumps in here and
goes it's that weak hoodie he's wearing
stopping his brain flow Darion
Darian you asked me to drink milk I
drank milk we've been buying it for
weeks what's going on
the chat is turned against me it's a sad
State of Affairs here I hate that I see
I see thumbs up though so we're getting
good people are in on it Dr 87 wants
Pollard I'm with you I'm with you I'm
with you in spirit
um I honestly may do that I honestly may
do that on the side I'll bet this and
I'll bet the other one all right yeah
all right I I think we're lucky all
right Ryan give it to him one more time
I feel like we locked it in give him a
parlay one more time for the people that
just joined the show
all right so in the first game of the
divisional run weekend we have Travis
Kelsey scoring against the Jacksonville
Jaguars minus 150.
later tonight Isaiah Hodgins scoring
against the fraudidelphi Eagles plus
265. tomorrow first game Stefan Diggs
minus 105 scoring against the Cincinnati
Bengals and cooking Eli apple and then
the last like Christian McCaffrey minus
155 against uh the team he will lose to
the Dallas Cowboys ah I don't know about
that one but make sure you guys tell us
on DraftKings and it wouldn't be right
if I didn't do a little anytime
touchdown boost magic so we're also
gonna boost Jamar Chase anytime
touchdown from plus 130 to plus
175 so go get it now
um it's time for our Best Bets it's time
for our Best Bets and I'm gonna get
straight to it I'm gonna get straight to
my pick I'm rocking with the G-Man from
New York today give me the points I'm
not saying money line give me the points
I think this is going to be a close game
I think this one's gonna be closer uh
than eight points so uh I'm rocking with
the points I'm rocking with saquon I'm
rocking with Daniel Jones I'm rocking
with the boys going to Philadelphia
who's on the bye week
sometimes teams you know when they come
out to bye week they come out playing
slow going to Philadelphia was on that
bye week and uh
I'm not going to say they win but I
won't be so surprised
I'm not gonna say they win but I won't
be surprised if they win because I'm
gonna be been that plus eight uh Sam
talk to us what you rocking with today
well I'm I'm going head-to-head against
you guys
um you know I I got some inside info
that Ryan is also against me here but I
am taking an eagles bills moneyline
parlay pays out around minus 120 minus
125 but yeah you know I'm on the other
side of you guys like I'm not buying
into the Giants I think you know Daniel
Jones looked great last week but he was
playing one of the worst teams in the
league in the Minnesota Vikings who were
a six-win quality team
um so I I don't put too much stock in
that Eagles have been you know one of
the best teams all year they're healthy
or sorry they're getting healthier
Elaine Johnson back hurts back
um I think the rest helps or at home I
just think the Giants are just not of
that caliber 29th in defense and dvoa
there's your first give you I mentioned
so I don't think they're there
um and then other other game I'm taking
the bills money line I I just think the
the Bengals were very lucky to get past
the Ravens which is telling considering
they were going against Tyler Huntley uh
they got out gained they got out game
the week before by the Ravens with third
stringers I just think the Bengals are
another class
um you guys are laughing so I'm gonna
stop my handicap and kick a try
parlay for this week Sam I'm not
laughing at you bro I'm laughing at the
comments the chat is hilarious I'm in
the chat Ryan before I let you go I just
have to say this somebody uh double ooh
Double U says I don't like this part
like Greg didn't give Ryan no pushback
on anything something isn't right
it is weird it is weird that we're all
lives together on this
it's honestly though like when was the
last time we had an anytime touchdown
parlay I think we needed this we needed
to come together as a family and say
this is the week
this is the week yes I'm I'm confident
this because we all right give the
people your pick brother uh real quick
uh Sam you haven't ever faded New York
before right
I can't remember oh I can't remember
anything okay we'll have to look we'll
have to look back uh but Greg you're a
smart man right because you have now
sided with the man who's eight and two
on his Best Bets the best bet King they
called me 500 overall for the NFL season
yeah put that in there who has few four
Futures very much all very much alive I
don't I only have one thank you also if
you're only tailing the Best Bets you're
a rich man or a woman or woman right
exactly uh anyway you see it in the
graphic Giants plus eight uh the Giants
are I've seen the story before with the
Giants I've done this song in dance it's
the same chorus they're a flawed team
they're not a good team but guess what
they're going to go into Philadelphia
against a hurt Jalen hurts with Nick
siriani who's a poo poo coach in a
loudmouth and make it a close game I
think you're gonna win your Cowboys in
Philly Philadelphia hey infiltrate your
bets you can't bet like that listen by
the way when I say eight and two one of
those losses was this exact game it was
a Giants Eagles game that I took the
Giants and I think the spread was almost
the exact same I think it was seven and
a half and that's the number I got it
out unfortunately you hate Philly
everyone knows that I know I hate Philly
yeah and guess what they're not that
good they're not they're good whoa whoa
they're good no they're good bro no
they're good they're good no they stick
I would take if both Daniel Jones and
Jalen hurts were free agents today I
would sign Daniel Jones to a mega Max
Steel that's her you might Ritter
yeah
can we can we like Daniel Jones is the
guy Daniel Jones is the guy now
it's tough your Cowboys fan is saying
Daniel Jones is the man
uh there it is
Daniel Jones is the guy I he just you
know I again I've seen this with the
Giants before they have a a not good
quarterback as their quarterback who
then goes into you just said he's better
than Jalen hurts well I mean seconds ago
because he's he's a he's a clutch and
he's going to be a legend this
postseason and he's probably out of
control man you can't even keep your own
take straight it doesn't matter if the
pick hits does the cat matter I don't
think it does the people of the Cub has
said that's crazy y'all trolling
dr87 I'm not with you I'm not with you
anymore buddy Rhett's in the chat please
friends
[Laughter]
if they cover this doesn't matter to
take that again you have to understand I
walk into the show every single week
with an agenda with a narrative that I'm
trying to push this is the narrative I'm
trying to push the Giants are better
than the Eagles I don't know if you're
trying to push is that Daniel Jones is
Elite well also bad which is just yes
that is true no how do you not
understand that he's Elite when he needs
to be aka some people call that clutch I
called Elite for agenda purposes but he
stinks
the Eagles bills bills moneyline enough
because the chat is saying you're
trolling the chat wants us to be free
he's not trolling he actually believes
these pigs somehow in his own mind
I don't know how but he does bowling
wants me to put down the Everclear
that's tough oh all we want is the dry
ice to cover uh let's get let's get out
of here man just went just tonight yeah
well when the cover I I don't care when
when because I don't want all of us to
win I don't I didn't like this
Vibes that's not true no no I didn't
like I didn't like the whole I didn't
like what you just did there to end the
show to cut me off to that I'm I'm a
lunatic so Giants money Giants well not
that's nothing
tell them
someone made maybe the most absurd
comment I've ever seen which is Sam
Richmond's Sam Richmond thinks there's
value on anything he bets which I say to
you
of course I do everyone should think
that about anything they bet is anyone
going to a bet like I don't think
there's any value here but I'm betting
it so you know what hgz 26 you're
correct I do think there's value on what
I'm betting yeah
there it is Sam's Sam's thinks there's
value on everything he's betting Ryan is
all over the place he thinks Daniel
Jones is a
Superstars I'm in one place Giants plus
eight one yeah but you just also said uh
Dale Jones is better than Jalen Harris
that is true that is true
yeah we we got a cut on that one uh my
name is Greg Ivory next to me is Sam the
man uh wait hold on hold on I'm sorry
before we get up out of here Ryan review
the parlay for everybody
one more time I gotta read this like I
got my throat's getting dry from the
amount of times I read this parlay bro I
mean the people want to know all right
the people want to know uh it's Travis
Kelsey anytime touchdown Isaiah Hodgins
anytime touchdown Stefan digs anytime
touchdown and Christian McCaffrey
anytime touchdown four legs plus 1853
odds are DraftKings anytime Boost from
the magician Greg himself is Jamar Chase
anytime touchdown plus 175. uh and our
Best Bets Greg smartly on Giants plus
eight also said Daniel Jones for MVP
sprinkle Dundee
we missed that in the graphic uh Sam
fraudman is on uh Eagles bills moneyline
parlay and then
the king of the best bet uh Giants plus
eight Daniel Jones is Elite all right
before we get out of here uh somebody
says something about your mustache and
shaving it if the parlay loses don't you
have a bet already with your mustaches
well the reason I'm I'm donning a
mustache is because I lost last week we
bet on okay the Ravens Ravens Bengals I
bet on the Bengals to cover he bet on
the Ravens to cover and and we know how
that that song and dance went so uh yeah
I think I think if giants don't cover
Ryan should shave the mustache I see you
want me to go clean shave that's what
you want wait wait Ryan do you like
mustache or you don't like mustard uh I
go back and forth on it this isn't like
a look that I would like Don permanently
it's it's something I'm doing because I
lost the bet I will say sam texted me
yesterday and was like don't make me
actually enforce the yeah that's gonna
be a good guy and say you know you don't
have to because you know you've got your
Seasons ending this week you're gonna
maybe you have to do a food challenge
you know a lot going on in your world
it's not happening it's Cowboys money
line this weekend everyone knows that
no way yes
yes we can make a bet we can make a bet
I need handlebars coming down from the
mustache for me if the 49ers win yeah
handlebar and can I get chin hair or is
it just no no
[Laughter]
it's my negotiation
straight handle bars with the stash if
the Niners win the Niners win all right
then you got what do you want from me uh
that's a good point
I didn't think about this now I'm
remodeling your face in real time what
is this
I'll go clean shave we'll go clean shave
Greg clean shave I ain't did that in a
minute yeah
all right we're offline about this
my name's Greg Ivory next to me is the
man the myth the legend I call him Sam
Richmond next to him is the man we like
to call producer Ryan uh hey you guys
follow our place we about to get rich
today we about it here let's go Niners
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]